[Musique]
c'est quand même quelque chose cet
enchevêtrement d'inconnus enfermés
ensemble pendant des jours qui n'ont
rien en commun sauf le besoin d'aller
d'un endroit à un autre et qui ne se
reverront jamais je sens quelque chose
de malfaisants dans ce train
un passager est mort alors ils ont fini
par l'avoir vous pensez qu'il a été tué
non non non non non mais il était temps
en excellente santé et il avait des
ennemis en effet il a été assassiné
seigneur un meurtre ici quelqu'un est
venu fouiller dans ma cabine en plein
milieu de la nuit et personne n'a voulu
me croire
s'il ya eu un meurtre mais que se
passe-t-il alors il y à un meurtrier le
meurtrier est parmi nous et chacun de
vous est suspect et vous guide et vous
je m'appelle hercule poirot et je suis
sans doute le plus grand détective du
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]